welcome back to cbs this morning in a
new memoir president biden's son hunter
deals head-on with the decisions that he
put him front and center
of the 2020 presidential campaign
beautiful things
is a revealing look at his long battle
with addiction
and how he's handled personal tragedies
it comes out tomorrow from gallery books
an imprint of simon
schuster a division of viacom cbs we
spoke with hunter biden about whether
his business dealings ever
crossed a line including work for a
ukrainian company
that became a big issue in president
trump's first impeachment
also whether he regrets putting his
father's political future
at risk the question of whether i would
do it again
though is no you wouldn't do it again
i wouldn't in his new memoir hunter
biden defends his decision to serve on
the board of ukrainian energy company
barisma
while his father oversaw u.s policy in
the region
as vice president you grew up in
politics
did you not think you might be putting a
big bull's-eye on yourself
i didn't fully comprehend the level
to which this
former administration and the people
around it would go
the difference between the politics that
you're talking about
in terms of the last uh you know 40
years
it's a very different game and i don't
ever want
to again to to to hand
a weapon to people that would
use it uh in a illegitimate and way that
they've
used the weapon to me against my dad
near the end of the 2020 campaign
another weapon emerged this laptop is a
disaster for them
how the hell did he ever let go of this
sucker allies of president trump
and supporters in the media promoted
incriminating evidence
allegedly found on a laptop belonging to
biden
you've seen the pictures folks it was
delivered to the fbi
by the owner of a delaware computer
store you make
just one reference to it at the book
yeah is that laptop yours
uh it's you don't need the laptop you
got a book
you got the book it's all in the book
and i don't know i actually
that you don't know the serious answer
is that i truly do not know the answer
to that
did you leave a laptop with a repairman
not to wilmington
no no but whether or not
um somebody has my laptop whether or not
it was my uh my was hacked whether or
not there
it exists a laptop at all i truly don't
know are you missing a laptop
not that i know of but you know i just
you read the book and you'll realize
that i wasn't keeping the
tabs on possessions very well for about
a four-year period of time
at the end of last year biden
acknowledged an ongoing investigation
by federal authorities for potential tax
law violations
is your legal team working on any kind
of a plea deal oh no
i am absolutely certain that what we're
doing is is being completely cooperative
with whoever is asking from a
from any authority whatsoever the
implication all through the campaign was
that your efforts
somehow benefited your father
financially have you ever given your
father money from any of your
business ventures no nothing nothing
ever
not a nickel not a nickel directly or
indirectly directly or indirectly
not a nickel ever 100 percent no
never in 2018 near the height of his
battle with addiction
biden misplaced a handgun sparking a law
enforcement investigation
new details emerged last month that the
secret service may have become involved
improperly it's a
concern that i would hurt myself or do
something ali your
your brother's widow threw the gun away
she was trying to protect you
i think she yes yeah i think she was
just concerned about me why did you have
a gun
well i did again you know the period of
my life
that um was difficult it was um
but you know i i don't know
hallie's intent was to to make certain
that i didn't do anything to hurt myself
according to the reporting at one point
the secret service went looking for the
record of sale do you
know anything about that nothing no no
no idea did somebody report the loss of
the gun oh yeah
they they had um at in the moment uh you
know
we knew that the gun was lost that
uh hallie had thrown it into a trash can
and i told her that you can't do that um
when i
realized that it was gone and so she
went back
and and they the police came to help
retrieve the gun which was retrieved
someone had gone through the trash and
picked it up and they found it within
hours i believe
and so that was the end of the story but
you know about the secret service being
involved no i had no idea
i don't know whether the secret service
were or why they would be or i don't
think that that's
true yeah to my knowledge the secret
service told cbs news it has no record
of its agent being
agents being involved in the incident
and joe biden was not
under protection at that time in our
next hour we talked to hunter biden
about his decades-long struggle
with alcohol and cocaine plus why after
the death of his brother beau he turned
to crack
and says he tried to disappear
there's a lot there yeah i mean it's
interesting that he says that
he wouldn't do it again getting on the
board but he doesn't think
he doesn't seem to he's not apologizing
for taking the job
he won't do that he he he realizes now
that it got his trump his father
um in some trouble and and he regrets
that but he's not apologizing he says i
was qualified
i had every right to serve you framed
the question the right way though you
grew up in politics how could you not
have known
yeah i think i think just knowing what
he
knowing what he knew about politics he
should have anticipated it i think
that's the argument
he claims he never thought it would be
this bad and there's a lot he doesn't
remember too
yeah well when you've been through what
he's been through that's not surprising
that's par for the course